in this episode of cloud performance
atlas we take compute engines disk
options for a spin will their
performance leave us dizzy stay tuned to
find out when we talk about the cloud we
tend to over index on things like
compute and network because quite
frankly those are the things that the
cloud can do which the machines sitting
under your desk can't but with this
focus we tend to forget something disks
see all that data you're processing has
to go somewhere and on Google cloud
platform choosing the right type of disk
can make a huge difference in the
performance of your application as such
let's take a look at what type of disk
options are available and what their
performance looks like in Google cloud
platform there are two main types of
disk local SSDs and persistent disks
local SSDs are pretty much what you'd
expect a drives that are physically
attached to your virtual machine
instance so when your VM spins down
shows as the data on the disk persistent
disks on the other hand are network
storage devices that act like a local
storage device with the upside being
that they can persist even after your VM
stops and can even be reattached to a
new VM later and on the persistent disk
side it's worth noting that there's two
flavors standard and SSD which behave
pretty much the same except one is a lot
faster than the other now I understand
that every application is different and
has unique needs which might make you
choose one of these options from the
other but from my perspective I care
about the best performance for the best
price to get a sense of this a small
benchmark test shows us how each of the
disks performed measuring number of i/o
operations per second per gigabyte of
data directly we see a very clear trend
local SSDs outperform both types of
persistent disks which completely makes
sense given that local SSDs are
physically connected to the VM so we
should see better perf this graph also
shows us that as far as the persistent
disks go the SSD variant outperforms
their standard counterparts quite easily
but this doesn't really tell the full
story which is why I like to break up
the graph between throughput and I ops
to help figure out what disk is the best
use case for what application scenario
for example boot disk volumes and bulk
storage are
rate matches for standard persistent
disks because they require very low I
ops and low throughput basically you
just want to occupy the cheapest most
reliable space available
likewise streaming IO works best with
standard persistent disks since the cost
per throughput is generally a little
better now relational databases tend to
be more i UPS heavy and while smaller
instances might be able to run on
standard PD you really want your
production deployments running on some
sort of SSD flavor disk file servers
mostly fall in the SSD PD camps since
they can either be more streaming or
more transactional depending on what the
clients are doing and finally high
performance scratch disks tend to
perform best on local SSD which is also
an ideal use case for things like Hadoop
deployments now it's worth reiterating
that each of the three disk options have
various types of configurations that can
change how they perform under different
workloads which is why we've gotten more
videos on the way so make sure you check
out the rest of the cloud performance
Atlas content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts